and our next guest is leading the senate
push to declassify intelligence on the
coronavirus outbreak indiana republican
mike braun
sits on the senate appropriations and
health committees i think to set it up
sir let's just show an exchange
between you and dr fauci yesterday
since you believe in transparency
wouldn't you think
that we should declassify all the
information
the most likely uh scenario is that this
was a natural occurrence
but no one knows that 100 percent for
sure since no one absolutely knows that
i believe we do need the kind of
investigation where there's open
transparency i'm not sure if it's my
place to tell the president of the
united states
and i think he'd respect your opinion as
much as any white house
all right so senator this is what i want
to ask you the intelligence
uh it could include sources and methods
right i mean that is also
a possibility that they would have to
consider what do you think you might be
able to find
if we had access to that private intel
so number one something is afoot
because when you get dr collins dr fauci
i went right after senator kennedy
drilling in and they did
almost everything they could to avoid
saying yes
we need to declassify but they knew they
couldn't so
we'll not only i think find out and give
us the trail
to start down with information that we
own
and why wouldn't you do it because the
more i look into it
this was squashed out of the gate by
eco health nih especially who
and china itself so the american public
deserves it
the world deserves it with all the
turmoil that's been caused by it
so then what next peter ducey in the
press room yesterday
with the question and answer would the
president seek to punish
china i we're not going to go there just
yet we have to go through the 90
day review is that something if another
nation
either was responsible or knew more than
they were letting up what
would the president do would he do
anything i mean he's doing something
right now
he's been he asked his team back in
march right to do
to do this to look into this in in the
meantime out of beijing the chinese
communist party has said case closed
we've done our investigation and we've
reached our own conclusions it's done
it's over with do you honestly think
senator that we'll ever get a
straight-up answer from the chinese
government
it depends on how compelling any of the
information that's starting to float
around the edges currently it's
complicated
when you've tried to squash this from
the beginning and when
trump pompeo and others wanted to pursue
it tom cotton was talking about this
over a year ago so there's a lot of
political crow you'd have to eat
to really be investigative in an
aggressive way that i think will get to
the bottom of it
i've researched what the odds are about
this coming out of a lab versus a
natural
infection and clearly from the get-go
it was you needed to be more uh
prying to find out and it is just all
cascading forward now
the biden administration's got a tough
political straddle
and transparency like i teased out of
collins and fouchy yesterday we'll see
if they want to be that or just give it
lip service
sir have we hit upon possibly a one of
the only bipartisan issues in the senate
right now
this headline from politico democrats
back growing calls for congress a probe
covet lab
theory um what do you think so
when you get two conservative senators
like myself and senator holly
on the floor of the senate and you do
not get a democrat
contesting it where it goes through by
unanimous consent
you know how rare that is that tells me
that they did not want to be on record
to at least not be interested in
transparency
it tells me that they know this is going
to be unleashed in a way
where they got to be engaged more than
they have been in the past
rather than dismissing it bringing up
words like xenophobic
all the things they did because they
were invested in the opposite approach
because the trump administration had the
opposite
point of view of theirs so it'll be an
interesting kind of
evolution over the next few uh days and
weeks senator thank you for your time
we're watching it very closely as you
can tell mike braun from indiana thanks
thank you